[Music]
okay now we're going to say to the
mushrooms with olive oil in there yeah
get nice and hot we'll go first with the
pompadour more there you go good girl
then the head in the top in and then
finely chopped oh nice lovely put a
little bit of butter in there
nice I love the deep complex flavor of
wild mushrooms but we can't get them
chestnut or fill mushrooms still deliver
great taste
mushrooms work really well with pumpkin
because they have a warm earthy flavor
that complements the pumpkin beautifully
so mushrooms into the center yeah from
there we got the parmesan and just peel
nice long layers watch very carefully no
just sit on top are the parmesan helps
to season the mushroom and really give
off an amazing flavor okay we're gonna
blend the soup and all we're gonna do is
half fill the blender so the soup gets
really nicely aerated now there's a bit
of a naughty chefs trick a little knob
of butter in there just in Tom so when
it blends it gets really nice and smooth
lid on onto the blender now we'll just
pulse it on and off first
[Music]
nice Wow
and this is a moment we will be waiting
for just one side of the bowl so that's
daddy's portion that this little bit is
yours
mmm no it'll taste blow gently
[Music]